[Music]
we are agreed
nice people only as D Xiao foo you Loker
I'd here
dismissed just as quickly we are the
best kept secret in the galaxy I want in
[Music]
20 years ago you erased my parents
memories that you didn't get mine we
don't hire we recruited then I'd like to
be recruited one another truth of the
universe suit up
welcome to the men in black
the men in black goat then start I'm
working on it we have a problem in
London
[Music]
hmm welcome to my be moving lady
topped off walking through you will be
with Asian teams come on
well it's not going to save itself I'm
driving that really should be here
the hive is a deadly species that can
take the form of anyone even our own
agents I haven't seen that before we
need more firepower he's pointed to bad
guys and pull the trigger
come on the men and women sometimes you
have to trust your gut
yeah baby Joey I thought that we were
here
step on it would you Freddie you gotta H
even though who you're dealing here we
protect the earth and everyone and
everything on it
that was awesome we are the men in black
are you suggesting that we try most
powerful weapon in the galaxy for fun
yeah maybe turn it up with you not sure
we are a rumor
ignitable only as deja vu and dismissed
just as quickly
we are the best-kept secret in the
universe I know I want in you erase my
parents memories but you didn't get mine
took me 20 years to find you how many
people can say that I found you
which makes me perfect for this job
[Music]
[Music]
you will be with agencies I might be you
Karelian scum and fYI your little Club
here sucks
come on world's not gonna save itself
I'm driving that really should be here
no exaggeration Joey I thought that we
were here we are
Freddie you go to eggs
[Music]
wait are you a queen indeed she is I
pledged loyalty eternal to you no no I'm
not interested too late I already
pledged the loyalty I wish you'd said no
no no before we've never faced a threat
like the hive they can take the form of
anyone I haven't seen that before even
our own agents do we have a plan
no sometimes you have to trust your gut
men and black has been compromised on
trust no one we protect the earth
and that means everyone and everything
on yeah baby we love a man in black
the men and women in black yeah
perfectly good are you suggesting that
we try the most powerful weapon in the
galaxy for fun do it
turn it up as you always remember the
universe has a way of leading you to
where you're supposed to be at the
moment you're supposed to be there let's
do this
it took me 20 years to find you how many
people can say that
you are the best-kept secret in the
universe and I found you which makes me
perfect for this job
you really think a black suit
it's going to solve all your problems no
but looks damn good on you we
[Music]
recognizable only as deja vu and
dismissed just as quickly time to prove
yourself agent M we may have a problem
in London welcome to MIB you will be
with Asian Paints one of the best ever
to weather suit catching up on my daily
meditation time for lunch oh thank you
hungry it's 9:30 it's Tuesday's taco day
[Music]
we've been compromised with every
citizen of this planet at risk
[Applause]
we could all just the tribe here just
try
gonna be fun left fun with it
there should be a big red button around
here somewhere found it we are the men
in black
looks like a tailless of time
I was incredible
[Music]
[Music]